hi I'm cat Allman with Google's open
source team I'm here today with one of
my favorite colleagues Jeremy Allison of
the Samba project to tell you all about
samba hi Jeremy I can't so starting in
general terms elevator speech what is
saba so samba is a file print an
authentication server and that sounds
incredibly boring because it is it's
basically part of the glue that allows
computers to connect to each other
unlike the internet it's an older
technology that's designed for local
file sharing so you know rather than
being somewhere and connecting to your
Wi-Fi and wondering where a printer is
with the SMB technology that samba
influence which is commonly used by
Windows clients you browse your local
network and you would print or get
access to local resources it's it's the
technology used behind Microsoft Active
Directory if that helps you mentioned
windows and I always thought Samba was
all about making windows resources
available to everybody else and vice
versa um so it's it's about making linux
and unix machines export resources to
windows clients but these days SMB is
actually been quite widely adopted by
both linux and mac less so by android
although there are many apps that that
will talk SMB so it's less of a
windows-only technology and there are
people actually who use SMB going
between unix to unix which is very
strange from where it started yes it is
yeah how many people are touched by
samba I mean is this something that only
developers use or is it under the hood
it's I like to refer to it as plumbing
which is nice because it means I'm the
equivalent of a plumber with a you know
plunger
removing blockages so it's it's the
technology that's used behind many many
network attached storage devices so as I
like to yoga if you go into fries or any
other electronic store and you buy a
disc that's advertised as network
attached storage something that you
would be able to connect to over your
wireless LAN or or of your wired LAN
that that stores your music medium
whatever i like to say if it costs under
ten thousand dollars it's got somewhere
inside it so it's actually it's actually
used in a great number of products Roku
set-top boxes things and some set-top
boxes but they mainly use the client
piece because the set-top boxes want to
access the resources and the client
piece is actually built into Linux which
is commonly used for those boxes Samba
itself the project is more of the server
side piece which is what runs on the
network attached storage that exports do
the clients so it's more like netgear
you know Western Digital you know many
of the many of the network attached
storage blanking on a lot of their names
right now that's okay it's also started
to be used in class what's called cloud
gateway storage so people who want to
get access to resources stored in the
cloud but don't nest at our think
they're talking to a local file but are
actually talking to cloud storage what
quite a few companies are doing now is
using Samba as a gateway so they have a
device that they will sell you that
actually pretends to be a local file
server but he's actually accessing
resources that exist out in the Internet
cloud so when did Samba start how did
you come up with this and it wasn't just
me um it was actually originally created
by myself and a friend of mine and root
riddle in Australia and it's actually
older than the Linux kernel or around
the same age so it's a very old
established project is about 20 21 years
old
and essentially he was a PhD student who
was trying to find something else to do
rather nice these studies and writing
diseases and I was actually working for
a company that needed to share files
between windows and unix machines and
was completely fed up with the only
thing that was being sold at the time
which was PC NFS which was horrible so
essentially we banded together and
started to develop something better that
taught the windows protocols and it
attracted more developers and has grown
from there really how many developers
are generally speaking contributing to
the project well it varies we've we've
had we have a lot of no um nine people
who've come through worked on the
project and gone on to better and
brighter things many of them actually
work at Google arm and you know that we
have people like myself who stayed
working on the project for its entire
lifetime and also Volker landecker who's
a has a German company that supports
amber and I would say there are probably
about 10 to 15 active developers so it's
actually quite a small project there are
many many other peripheral developers
people doing testing people doing QA
people who come in to fix a specific bug
that there's really bugging them and
then go away again if they've got the
fix in than they need and summers your
full-time job here and eighty percent so
most Googlers have twenty percent time I
have eighty percent time but twenty
percent of the time I'm doing things for
you nice nice okay are you hearing on
these interviews this kind of thing oh I
understand you just released a new
version what three weeks ago actually
the the big new version came out about a
year or so ago and that was some before
we have we release versions fairly
regularly so you know a new release
isn't unless it's a major release you
know it's it's mainly bug fixes of
interest to people who are following the
project
because everything's fixed but the big
new release we did which was Sam before
was our first implementation of an
Active Directory domain controller so
for the first time you can actually have
Windows clients talking to and
cooperating with a domain controller and
Active Directory domain controller full
active directory that is not made by
microsoft and it will interoperate with
Microsoft Active Directory domain
controllers and in fact Microsoft have
worked with us and fixed actually fix
some bugs on the windows client side to
make this work for us so um I'm very
happy about that that's a really cool
new thing all right great um are you
looking for new contributors to the
progress actually the most open source
projects we're desperate we can always
do with more contributors so the kind of
things that we need our while sandbur is
written in C so it's a kind of an old
project so if if you really want to do
sort of down and dirty very hard
technical work Sam was the place to do
it there's a lot of very hard very
technical work than he's doing lots of
bugs that need fixing you can learn
about very many core technologies by
working on Samba security technologies
file sharing technologies how to do
encryption all these kind of things but
we also need people who can help
document it because like most open
source projects it's terribly documented
we have I think we have a record for the
longest man page I think something like
35 hundred pages all of which are
configuration options many of which are
confusing and so so what would really
help is people who could actually help
right people who can write people who
can help technical writers essentially
and also people who can do QA quality
assurance there's just and also people
who can help market it people who can
help explain how it works right up
scenarios we have a wiki that describes
how it's used and how
how he can be used there are it's so big
and it's so flexible it's hard to
describe in a short time but the great
reason for doing so is that I get pinged
regularly my company's looking for
engineers who are so more experienced
real so if you're looking for a job and
you know you're in the technical
industry working on Samba is a very very
good way to get one so Wow ok so where
do people go so Sam Borg is I mean
website and everything is under there
this the wiki this the git repository
there's all the mailing lists to get
started I would recommend joining the
Samba mailing list and that's mainly for
users of samba if you want to get a
little more technical we have a Samba
technical mainly list and then we have a
sandbar bash technical and Samba IRC
channel on freenode net which is the
main open source open source IRC server
anything else you want to tell people
about the project I assume it's funny
that a long time doing it's amazingly
fun the thing about it is it keeps
changing and this is this is why I still
work on it this is why I still find it
fun and interesting you can work on a
simple things as you know parsing
configuration files you know very very
simple bug fixes all the way up to
research level projects that are funded
by IBM to do with distributed clustered
file storage technologies and
synchronizing file systems between many
hundreds of machines and it's all
they're all they're in the code and it's
you know I won't say it's available in
small bite-sized chunks but everything
is there this is this is the wonderful
thing and the wonderful thing about most
open source is that by working on this
stuff you can see code that is used in
the real world you're not if your
student and you're looking at this stuff
you're not working on toy projects
you're not working on tiny things that
you know
your professors have assigned you know
to solve trivial problems you're working
on real problems that real engineers are
using in real-world solutions you're
actually seeing the code the glue that
holds the world together and it's the
real thing you can make a difference you
can actually contribute and change it
yourself and that that's just
intoxicating it's just that's kind of
how I got started it's like I send the
patches over here and they turn up and
the product it's amazing you know you
can actually change the world with this
stuff I'm not only stealing that line
about this is the glue that holds the
world together fair enough yeah it's
it's absolutely compelling if you're an
engineer or if you're interested in
technical things I can't imagine
anything more fun to do fantastic well
Thank You Jeremy oh thank you can thank
you all of you for joining us urge you
to go to Samba org and check it out and
if it ignites even a tiny fraction of
the passion that jeremy has for samba
I'd encourage you to consider becoming a
contributor thank you very much bye